amnesty international has claimed that
since the protests spread across the
country two weeks ago at least
56 people have died 38 of them
on tuesday alone our africa
correspondent john sparks spoke to
bernard boy about the end
sars protest movement and how it's
changed the nature of politics in
nigeria
this is the most important moment in
nigeria's history
the most by far important moment of
nigeria's history
that's what we're witnessing right now
you know because
if if nothing changes after this if
if this doesn't work then
you know it's over
and i'm sober what do you mean by that
it's over i mean
look at what's going on now
the youth have come together yeah
like something
something on unexplainable something
that no one man could have possibly
organized or
led yeah the
the youth of the who of the largest
black nation
in the world came together
and decided enough is enough and this
this was triggered by
police brutality right
it's not like it was triggered by all
the other things that it should have
been triggered by
all these years yeah it was triggered by
this police brutality that has been
happening forever
and we find the fight we finally decided
enough is enough
you can't just you can't just kill all
these all these people
in this place who are who whose only
crime
is asking for a future
and not have any explanation whatsoever
as to how
it happened just saying so one person
who says powers beyond this control
the other person say oh he didn't know
it was this the other person would say
oh this person instructed us to opt
to turn off the light that where are we
going
where are we going
were you surprised at what young people
in nigeria managed
to do with those protests because you
have been critical
of the youth in nigeria you have said
they deserve the leaders they get
because they have been generally
apathetic
i mean yeah and i take those words back
now they made they made me eat those
words didn't they
you know because now yeah they
they they made something that i've only
seen in
in my in my wildest dreams
yeah a reality you know i didn't even i
never thought
that anything like this could ever
happen not even not in my lifetime not
when i'm dead
do you understand but now i feel so
blessed
and privileged to witness this day and
this age this liberation generation
and to be part of it is i feel like it's
the biggest achievement
it's the biggest thing my life like i've
ever seen in my life and i've ever been
a part of in my life
the government the military they want
the protesters
off the streets they've said look we've
we've met your demands it's time to go
home
they've said that before haven't they
they've said that twice or three
times haven't they
so what makes this time different so we
should go everybody should go home
because you say it again
show me and so far you've showed me his
blood of my people
so what are you telling me
have you seen what's happened in nigeria
musically does it inspire you
musically no no i don't care about no
music right now i don't
know that's not it's like it doesn't
matter to me right now none of that
matters to me